[Music]
are the borg really beyond saving when
can you trust an omnipotent trickster
captain john luke picard had some pretty
heavy decisions to make aboard the uss
enterprise keep watching to see the
absolute best
in the series premiere of star trek the
next generation riker first meets his
new captain in a ready room and is given
his first order right away it's an order
given sternly and sets the tone for
picard as a cold by the book commanding
officer but over the course of the
series the two would form one of just a
few genuine friendships for captain
picard and his choice to appoint him
first officer would alter the trajectory
of his life in that same first episode
one of picard's next acts as captain was
to instruct his new number one to
prevent him from making an ass of
himself with the children on the ship
i'm not a family man riker and yet
starfleet has given me a ship with
children aboard
over the course of the series riker
would help picard go from a stoic stick
in the mud who preferred to stay in
arm's length from his crew to a man with
friendly relationships with those under
his command
one could argue that the mere act of
recruiting data could be one of the
boldest decisions picard ever made
despite the android having a long and
distinguished service record that would
warrant just about any starship captain
bringing him aboard but while other
officers may have seen data as a mere
machine captain picard and those on the
enterprise learned to see him as so much
more even though visitors were routinely
surprised i must admit commander
i didn't think you'd be so
personable aboard the enterprise bacard
and his crew saw data as a person and
when his rights as an individual came
under attack they leapt to his defense
and when data was ordered to be turned
over to starfleet as property in the
measure of a man it was picard who was
at the forefront of the fight demanding
they could judge and decide his status
it was picard who acted as his defense
counsel in one of the most important
acts he'd perform as captain an act with
consequences that continue to
reverberate through the star trek
universe even today
in the first season of the next
generation there didn't seem to be any
set chief engineer on the enterprise but
in the second season premiere picard
would promote helmsman jordy laforge to
the permanent spot at the head of the
ship's engine room to audiences it may
have seemed like an odd jump for the
young officer but it proved to be one of
the key changes on the ship after its
first rocky year la forge went on to
become one of the standouts on the
series and was even ranked by screenrant
as the franchise's best engineering
chiefs he'd solve crisis after crisis
including several galactic threats and
it never would have been possible if he
stayed a mere pilot or been moved to a
different post
one of the most unexpected turns of
events in the entire run of star trek
the next generation occurred in the
third season episode sins of the father
essentially a sci-fi political drama the
episode brought the action to the
klingon homeworld with the sudden
accusation of treason made against
dwarf's dead father turning up on the
enterprise is worf's long-lost brother
kern who wants worf to travel home to
defend their family's honor but when
kern is the victim of an assassination
attempt worf finds himself alone and
captain picard steps in to help not as
captain of the enterprise but as a
trusted friend with picard's assistance
new evidence is discovered along with a
direct eyewitness that clears wharf's
father of the crime to prevent a civil
war however worf takes the fall but
averts a death sentence thanks to the
evidence picard revealed leaving justice
for another day
in season 3's hollow pursuits we met a
very unusual starfleet officer
lieutenant reginald barclay barclay was
far from the steady skilled and capable
men and women of starfleet barclay was
awkward clumsy and lacking in confidence
he was a social outcast who struggled to
fit in among the more gregarious and
bold crew of the enterprise i've
examined barclay's psychological profile
he has a history of seclusive tendencies
when it became known that he wasn't
measuring up commander riker wanted him
off the ship insisting he had no place
on the enterprise and suspecting that
barclays previous commanders might have
given him recommendations just to get
rid of him but just when it seemed like
picard might follow barclay's previous
captains and send him packing he decided
to do something nobody had done before
reach out to barclay with a caring
compassionate helping hand instead of
transferring the so-called problem
officer picard instructed jordy to
become his best friend
with all due respects are my best friend
i can barely tolerate being in the same
room with a man eventually the crew came
to appreciate barclay for all his unique
talents and skills and together helped
him come out of his shell eventually
he'd help bring the stranded crew of
voyager home safely saving hundreds of
lives
the mischievous queue was initially
presented as a malevolent god-like
entity with sinister but mysterious
motives he tormented the crew in the
premier episode and popped up again
throughout the series to cause mischief
and mayhem aboard the uss enterprise
he's back
but it's in the third season episode
deja q that picard makes his most
important decision regarding the
all-powerful q exiled from his own
people q was turned into a mere mortal
and suck refuge on the enterprise when
he became the target of a vengeful alien
race picard chose to help him and
provided q with a safe haven mostly
[Music]
seems human enough to me it wasn't an
easy call and few would have blamed him
if he hadn't agreed to come to his aid
particularly as q's presence proved to
be a danger to the ship but helping
queue showed the trickster how special
humans and picard really were q later
felt he owed jean-luc a debt of
gratitude he'd repay in cupid tapestry
and in the series finale all good things
helping him learn life lessons and save
mankind too had picard not intervened we
also may have never witnessed the q
civil war on voyager nor his return in
season 2 of star trek picard
who watches the watchers may be one of
the most quintessential episodes of star
trek the next generation it all starts
when a secret starfleet research team is
discovered by a pre-industrial society
called the mintakis and in the ensuing
confusion where the enterprise comes to
assist begin to believe that picard is
an all-powerful god the prime directive
demands they not interfere but the
damage is done and while the starfleet
expert advises they hand down a set of
religious tenants to mitigate the damage
picard outright refuses instead the
captain speaks directly to the primitive
people and plainly explains the
situation in the end the mintakens begin
to understand the truth of what happened
and agree to go their separate ways but
not before gifting picard with a
handwoven tapestry to remember their
time together
one of the major guest stars to appear
on star trek the next generation who
originated in the original series was mr
spock's father saric the elder vulcan
ambassador had appeared in the original
series and in three of the five feature
films before he showed up on the next
generation in the season 3 episode cerec
coming aboard the ship to conduct final
negotiations with a mysterious alien
race it's soon discovered that the aging
vulcan is afflicted with a rare disease
that is sapping him of his mental
abilities and his logic in the climax of
the episode picard selflessly agrees to
a dangerous mind meld with saric in
order to help him stabilize his
condition so he can follow through with
his final mission the meld is a success
but not without consequences and picard
undergoes some serious trauma as a
result
picard's joining with cerek's mind gives
him a more centered and measured sense
of control it also gave him a profound
connection to ambassador spock who he'd
meet and meld with in the episode
unification which in turn may even have
helped fuel his desire to help the
romulans in the follow-up star trek
picard when the enterprise first made
contact with the borg they were shown to
be little more than a robotic hive mind
intent on absorbing life into their
collective but in the episode iborg dr
crusher convinces picard to bring aboard
an injured and dying borg they find at
the site of a crashed borg ship
initially picard wants to use the drone
as a weapon against the collective using
a computer virus to sabotage their
entire network
the terminal one
but as the borg recovers it begins to
show signs of individuality eventually
taking the name hugh and showing an
unusually strong moral compass
ultimately picard chooses to respect
hugh's right to autonomy and lets hugh
make his own choice about his future
hugh decides to return to the collective
and picard's greatest hope is realized
that hugh's sense of self and morality
could be just as contagious to the borg
as any virus throughout the fourth
season trouble was brewing in the
klingon empire beginning with the death
of the former chancellor kim peck it's
determined that duross the same man
who'd framed wharf's father is guilty of
the assassination as well as the murder
of wharf's ex-girlfriend
that's enough reason for whorf to kill
duross in ritual combat the mysterious
gauran is named the new chancellor but
duros's powerful family haunts the
empire and it all comes to a head in the
two-part season ender redemption with
gauran about to take his place as leader
of his people the house of duras with
the outside help of the romulans attempt
to take control themselves torn between
his people and his duty dwarf sides with
gauran and asks that picard and
starfleet join him unable to get
directly involved in what is deemed an
internal klingon affair picard instead
hatches a plan to expose the romulan
alliance with the house of duros the
plan works gauran is installed as
chancellor thanks to picard's help and
dwarf finally regains the honor he had
lost in sins of the father it's a bold
and risky move for picard but it sets
off a chain of events that would have
after effects for years spilling over
into deep space nine years later as
gauran owes much of his legacy to
starfleet and picard's assistance
recruited by a corrupt admiral to help
locate a supposed bajoran terrorist
ensign rollern was brought to the
enterprise against picard's explicit
objections but when ensign row uncovered
a plot to supply cardassian militants
with illegal weapons she didn't know who
to trust with the help from gainan
ensign row placed her faith in captain
picard to help her out of the situation
gainan is very selective about whom she
calls a friend
rather than toss her into the brig for
taking part in a corruption scandal
picard impressed by her integrity asks
her to remain on the enterprise it may
have seemed like an obvious choice for
viewers in the moment who science and
row distinguish herself in the episode
but she was coming from a federation
penal colony and her reputation was less
than stellar giving her a position on
the bridge of the flagship of the
federation was a risky call and it paid
off in spades as rogue became a standout
officer and a fan favorite character
when star trek the next generation first
debuted in 1987 it was living in the
shadow of the original star trek series
and picard himself was being measured
harshly against his counterpart james t
kirk as played by franchise legend
william shatner thankfully patrick
stewart played the role masterfully and
picard eventually became equally as
beloved in his own way in the first next
generation film in 1994 star trek
generations the two captains of the
enterprise would come face to face
thanks to a fateful decision by captain
picard both captains became trapped in a
mysterious time-bending anomaly called
the nexus when picard attempts to escape
and stomp the villainous soren he
discovers kirk inside the nexus and
recruits him for the task together they
stop sorin and in the melee kirk dies at
soren's hands but saves millions of
lives in the process the decision to
bring kirk back for one more mission may
be the most important choice he ever
made not just to save lives but to give
trekkies the moment they'd been waiting
for the meeting of the two best
enterprise captains
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one